all right vlad why are some movie buffs  getting excited  that's because anthony mason the world's  last  blockbuster buster video is hosting a  once-in-a-lifetime  90s themed sleepover for only  four bucks say what four dollars yeah  four dollars  sandy harding the manager in ben oregon  is converting it into an airbnb for  three nights only september 18 18th  through the 20th  lucky guests can watch all sorts of  movies or they can play video games  in this makeshift check it out it's like  a makeshift living room with a sofa bed  it's got a vcr  you get free snacks like pizza popcorn  candy  the only catch guys it's reservations  for local customers  only to thank them for their support if  you're in bend oregon  i no i still have my blockbuster card in  case  you were wondering yeah does the vcr jam  does that vcr jam and eat the tape  that's my question  all right thanks vlad